bonjour à tous je vous ai parlé la
nouvelle dénomination des iphone pour
2018 ya quelque temps dans une
précédente vidéo et aujourd'hui on va se
concentrer sur un des produits
concentrés sur l'iphone x l'iphone 10
plus le grand écran le 6 5 pouces oled
et on va parler du style et qui devrait
arriver avec elle son lit va maintenant
alors c'est un truc de dingue apple il
ya des années nous disait en la personne
de steve jobs
il n'y aura jamais de style et qui veut
un style et les styles et c'est ridicule
je ne veux pas tirer le style c'est de
la merde sauf qu'aujourd'hui ils sont en
train de faire un peu machine arrière
alors on peut effectivement c'est en
2007 aujourd'hui on est en 2018
il ya une vraie évolution et ya surtout
samsung a sorti sa gamme notes avec un
stylet est un smartphone qui coûte quand
même plus de 1000 euros donc l'idée pour
apple c'est de se dire quitte à sortir
trois smartphones parents et là un
smartphone un iphone 10 plus très grand
autant carrément lui rajouter un stylet
comme ça on est en concurrence frontale
avec samsung et on peut piquer des parts
de marché à la gamme note c'est assez
malin c'est vrai c'est vrai il faut le
reconnaître et d'un côté les autres
smartphones n'ont pas de style et puis
ceux qui ne veulent pas quitter de
stylet sur son grand écran ne sont pas
obligés de le faire parce qu'a priori le
style et ne seraient pas vendus avec
alors on voit qu'effectivement
l'estiment quelque chose qui se
démocratise de plus en plus si apple
notamment sur l'ipad y avait l'ipad pro
avec son style est un outil vraiment
dédié aux professionnels pour dessein il
y avait un vrai sens d'avoir un style et
on pense notamment aux infographistes
aux architectes à toutes les personnes
qui vont faire la création ou qui ont
vraiment un besoin de stylet pour leur
travail
là il ya un vrai sens et justement on
voit qu'en 2010 it sorti un nouvel ipad
9,7 pouces sur lequel on peut adapter le
style est une fois de plus le stylet
n'est pas vendu avec
il faut l'acheter en plus alors il ya un
style et logitech que vous pouvez
acheter beaucoup moins cher directement
vendue aux états unis
ça peut valoir le coup mais dans tous
les cas ce qui est sûr c'est que on voit
que les styles et travon prendre tout
cas de plus en plus de place ne seront
pas compatibles avec tous les iphone
mais avec l'iphone 10 plus de cette
année il pourrait être compatible
c'est une prédiction qui nous vient de
roseanne blatt security a été relayée
par apple insider et qui parle
effectivement de ce nouveau
aux appareils compatibles avec un stylet
alors la question c'est est ce qu'on va
parler du style et qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui aurait alors qu'apple le
pencil d'apple ou est ce qu'on parle
vraiment d'un stylet à part light peine
comme on a le s pen de samsung pour
avoir l'ipad d'apple est ce qu a
contrario on garderait ce pencil qui un
peu plus grand ou est ce qu'on nourrit
un style et un peu plus petit pour ce
produit
forcément un peu plus petit donc c'est
vraiment une question très intéressante
parce que ça permettrait de rajouter
encore un autre produit dans la gamme et
comme je vous le disais de toute façon
ce peines il
quoi qu'il soit ne sera pas vendu avec a
contrario quand vous achetez un ipad pro
vous avez le stylet avec la vous avez
créé votre iphone 6 plus vous n'aurez
pas le style est compris avec la
stratégie pour apple est très clair
c'est pas mais de vente un produit très
cher à plus de 1000 euros le smartphone
plus haut de gamme le plus grand écran
oled le top du top le best du best et si
vous voulez avoir le style il va falloir
rajouter quelque chose comme 79 euros si
je dis pas de bêtise ça va forcément
augmenter l'addition augmenter le
chiffre est beaucoup plus intéressant
pour apple c'est vraiment très
intéressant parce qu'on voit vraiment
que chez apple il ya une vraie logique
qui évolue et qui change
on a vu avec l'année dernière l'arrivée
de l'iphone dit ce qui est censé être en
tout cas la vision d'apple pour le
smartphone pour le futur en réalité
l'iphone 10 et des innovations majeures
on va pas se mentir il ya fayza il dit
il ya un super grand écran bord à bord
quasi bord à bord qui marche très bien
il ya un design particulier il ya eu le
parti pris de se dire on va coller une
encoche en eau comme social phone
quelque chose qui marche bien d'ailleurs
ça a plutôt bien fonctionné parce qu'on
va que les smartphones android en
mettent de plus en plus que ce soit le
one + 6 que ce soit le webp 21 trophées
walheim et beaucoup de fabricants qui
met cette fameuse encoches de partout
donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant c'est
assez intelligent c'était une bonne
vision en tout cas c'est d'y rester un
produit sans qu'elles se positionner
donc on va que apple a vraiment revu sa
copie a dit on prend le meilleur de
toutes les technologies que ce soit de
la recharge par induction que ce soit
des grands écrans bord à bord du oled et
compagnie et on en fait un seul et grand
smartphone directement apple ce
smartphone ils vont décliner en trois
smartphones cette année un petit
la gamme l'iphone en cas d'écrans lcd un
autre un iphone 10 qui a peu plus haut
de gamme notamment par rapport à l'écran
avec un écran 5,8 pouces oled et ensuite
ce fameux iphone 10 plus avec un grand
écran oled et cette fameuse
compatibilité donc ce qu'on va vraiment
l'intérêt c'est de se dire pour les
personnes qui ne veulent pas forcément
mettre beaucoup d'argent dans un iphone
disent ils ont le design avec un écran
lcd
ça va coûter moins cher on va retrouver
un peu dans les prix un peu plus
raisonnable je me défende guillemets
comme tarzan calcio prêchèrent de ce
qu'on a vu au niveau des iphone celle
des iphone 8
on va retrouver dans des prix assez cher
pas forcément le prix de l'iphone 10 de
2017 avec un iphone disent qu'ils seront
un peu moins cher
et là on va exploser le plafond des
tarifs avec un iphone 10 plus et en plus
si vous achetez le style et ça va vous
coûter une blinde
on n'a pas se mentir mais on va vraiment
qu'à un vrai positionnement stratégique
pour aller sur des produits un petit peu
moins cher pour retourner un peu dans la
course parce que malgré tout c'est un
peu un frein la commercialisation en
masse de cet iphone 10 le tarif a plus
mille euros c'est quand même dingue au
même si effectivement ces jeunes y ont
trouvé à moins de 1000 $ une fois que
vous avez rajouté les différentes facs
françaises
ça me coûte une petite fortune donc on
voit une stratégie gagnante en
concurrence la gamme note de samsung on
se positionne face à la gamme s de chez
samsung toujours et on reste dans la
course avec un iphone un peu moins cher
d'autant plus qu'on devrait retrouver
aussi cette année un iphone s 2 special
edition qui va arriver très bientôt donc
rester qualité parce que on va en
reparler très prochainement d'air dites
moi ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous y croyez vous cette info
du steve et qui arriverait sur un grand
écran pour venir concurrencer la gamme
note de samsung est ce que ça vous
paraît pertinent oui non et si c'était
le cas est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter
est ce que le fait de tenir un iphone
avec un stylet vous seriez pas en train
de vous dire je suis dit ça me fait de
la peine de steve jobs
il a dit ce n'est pas possible et
aujourd'hui on en train de le faire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez dites moi
tout ça en commentaire une fois de plus
je vous invite à blesser des jolies
pousse des commentaires vous marquez vos
suggestions question tout ce que vous
voulez on va en parler là plein de
choses à se dire
je vous remercie d'avoir collé cette
vidéo vous restez connectés parce que
vous allez voir l'actuel n'attend pas il
ya plein de choses qui arrivent
les choses hyper cool donc on reste
ensemble à très bientôt son message
pouvait dér robeco et ciao salut